now our upcoming awards about software
which is pretty amazing over the last 20
years CG developers have created
exciting and powerful software tools
this has led to a revolution to a
revolution in the art and business of
moviemaking originally developed for
star wars episode one zeno is a software
system used for the creation of 3d
computer generated scenes it consists of
a framework that's the subject of this
award and applications which are written
as plugins think of it this way the
camera body is the framework the lenses
and the other accessories are the
plugins in this case different
applications can exchange data this
provides developers and artists with
flexible and reliable ways of adding
customizations for production some of
these tools include sculpting effects
simulations lighting and creating
dynamics for the development and
architecture of ILM's zeno application
framework the Academy presents Florian
cans Geoffrey Yost Philip Hubbard and
Jim who rehanne with a technical
achievement award on behalf of the four
of us here I would like to thank the
academy for this honor of course
building a large system like Zeno
requires a lot more than for engineers
even if you have a decade and we would
like to thank all the members of the R&D
group at ILM that have contributed to to
the core Zeno architecture or or who
have built world-class applications on
top of it there are too many to name
them all individually but Alain Tremblay
Kerry Phillips Charlie Kilpatrick and
Nikki Rasmussen stand out Xena would be
nothing without the artists that use it
in production every day and who
collaborate with us to make zeinab
better we would also like to thank the
leaders of the ILM are indeed group over
the years including Christian or a who
encouraged us to build Zeno as well as
anti Hendrickson Phil Peterson cliff
bloomer and Steve Sullivan who supported
Zeno and its integration into visual
effects production we don't like to
thank our families for their support and
putting up with us staying late at the
office knowing that when you see the
next Michael Bay extravaganza it was all
worth it thank you
you